[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la première dose d'astrazeneca ou après
la deuxième dose de files heures et
modern à
l'âme des personnes se détache
définitivement du corps
maintenant il ya personne qui en parle
au niveau scientifique parce que ce
n'est pas observable de façon
rationnelle de façon objective il ya une
déconnexion de l'âme
[Musique]
et
des enfants qui sont nés de personnes
vaccinées soit les deux soit 1 se
développent et on en est à peu près à
six mois elle disait je peux vous
témoigner que les enfants grimpent les
murs les enfants sont pas normaux à
mesure qu'ils grandissent on doit les
éloigner des dt des bébés humains et
parce qu'ils sont transhumance tous ceux
qui sont sérieusement impliqués dans
l'histoire de la science
finiront par comprendre un jour
qu'un esprit se manifeste dans les lois
de l'univers un esprit immensément
supérieur à celui de l'homme einstein